i am a
very very big uh fan of the 2004 dawn of
the dead movie
of course that movie is directed by zach
and
written by james gunn you've worked with
both of them so it was making me wonder
are there any shared traits between the
two of them as
writers and directors that makes you
drawn to working with them
um no
they're you know they're so they're just
so different in the way they do things
and uh you know i would be hard-pressed
to
make a similarity in anything that they
do
in the writing that they do and the you
know the directing that they do
or even the people that they are they're
just so very different
um but in great ways like they're both
both
artists they're both artistic and
intelligent and just uh
yeah i mean i but they were they were
just completely different experiences
i it would be hard to compare either of
them but i i
i can tell you this man i love both of
them and they've both done wonders for
me and been very good to me
but uh now as comparison you know as
people as directors just
apples and oranges in that case what is
something about zach in particular that
makes him
one of a kind a quality about him that
maybe you wish you saw in more sets out
there
well i mean you know to each his own
people do different you know things
different way and i
always respect you know the way people
do things but uh
i tell you what i love most about zach
is zach is just super rough around the
edges
like so this is why i look for people
like this for people
they're just kind of rough around the
edges because i am you know i i'm
i'm an athlete and i you know i'd rather
i you know i'd rather
be punching something to to work out
rather than you know
running or just uh i'm that type of guy
and i think zach is also
that type of guy he's just all tatted up
he just likes getting dirty and sweaty
and being out there and being on the
grind
and uh so i really i connected with him
in that way
and also here's the thing that is hard
for me to find i can find people all day
long like that
other fighters other wrestlers other
guys who are just super rough around the
edges
but it's really hard for me to find that
guy who's also an artist
at heart and zack is an artist at heart
like he really is and you
you know you look at him you probably
never think but man this guy is he can
just look through a camera
or he can see something and know that he
wants to put that image on film in his
in a in a beautiful way and that's
something that only comes from the eye
and the heart of an artist and
and i think that i have that as well i'm
very much a performance artist i have
the soul of an artist
but to look at me i would i look like i
just broke out of prison
you know i don't look nobody's going to
look at me and say
that guy's an artist jumping into
spoilers here i'll put the warning up
for our viewers because i i do want to
touch about the artistic quality of the
drama in this movie because your last
scene with ella was
was an emotional wallop that i wasn't
quite ready for so in a movie that is
wall-to-wall action what do you have to
do in order to
switch gears and tackle something like
that
oh man it's you know it's in that
particular moment
it wasn't it wasn't that hard because i
knew what the scene was i was ready for
it we went in the scene
with that mentality and a lot of times i
will just draw from experiences
and it's really not hard for me to get
there what is hard there was a
particular moment in the film
where i had to go from like one emotion
to another motion to another motion like
five or six different emotions
all in the like the span of like a
minute and like those things are hard
because it's just not easy because i
again my i don't have a theatrical
background i didn't go to drama school i
don't have that to rely on
i just draw from experiences that i've
had in my life and sometimes to switch
up those emotions that fast is just not
the easiest thing to do
not for myself anyway um so i but that
one particular scene i was
looking forward to because i wanted to
you know i wanted to bring that side of
my performance to the screen
and get you know allow people to see to
see that side of me as an actor
but also i really wanted people to
understand how much scott
loved his daughter and so because to me
that was kind of that's the heart of the
film that's the back one of the film
it's really scott
trying to redeem himself with it with
his daughter i love that quality of it
before they kick me out of here just for
fun if you had to pick your food truck
of choice
what would it be it would be um
all right so i would always i would do a
food truck that like
when i go out so i'm gluten-free and
dairy-free and like 90
plant-based and it's hard for me to go
out and find a food truck that i really
want to eat at
a lot of times even when you'll find
vegan trucks they're not always
typically gluten-free trucks
so i would have a
vegan gluten-free grilled cheese truck
for no one but myself i'm coming to your
food truck
that sends me i'm perfect again congrats
on this movie
it was a blast exactly what i needed
right now congratulations
yeah thank you